well I guess class is in session so
there were a number of videos that came
out Doctor Who related very very
recently there was sort of a
behind-the-scenes look with a couple of
glimpses of the Christmas special didn't
feel there was enough there for me to
really weigh in on the title has me
intrigued though and we also got to
things a teaser and then a proper
trailer for the new Doctor Who spin-off
this come out called class which is set
at the school that the doctor we've
already seen him at he was the care tag
taker at briefly and the one that Clara
worked at which of course if you know
you Doctor Who history also ties back
into where Susan his granddaughter was a
student way back in the very first
episode of Doctor Who back in the 60s
now between the two of them the teaser
did not do that much for me the teaser
came out first and it started with voice
over from the doctor gave us a few
glimpses of things I'm like oh okay it
didn't do all that much to intrigue me
but then a couple hours later the full
trailer dropped and I saw that one okay
now I'm interested I liked it first of
all that in the proper trailer they put
the doctor at the end of it because I
mean let's be honest if he appears in
this at all it's got to be like his
appearances in something like the Sarah
Jane Chronicles it's got to be sporadic
it's gonna be every now and then for my
money of this he shows up at the
beginning to set it up maybe in the
season finale we'll see what we get but
the trailer puts the focus much more on
these students these teachers what
they're dealing with an looks kind of
cool I like that I like that there
appear to be some teachers involvement
some older people as well as some
students I think that's a nice mix
because I think the just sort of only
the young people they have to hide it
from the adults that is a setup that
gets old really quick and is really kind
of play it out at this point we've got
the glimpse of these scenes they refer
to them as the shadows now for my money
that's what they deal with in the very
first episode it's possible that that
would be a sort of series long threat I
don't know we'll see but as I say every
like the way they snuck the doctor in
there at the end and I love the point of
reference that they make in terms of you
know these tears of space-time that are
there and are obviously gonna be the
source of all the problems they compared
it to the Hellmouth and Buffy thick
compared to the Vampire Diaries and even
kind of point out that that's a non
comparison for you to make but I like
that not only because do I think it's
sort of reaching out to the same sort of
audiences and throwing them a little
belt and saying hey if you like that
maybe like this so it's kind of a clever
marketing thing but even beyond that I
like that this exists in a world where
there is fiction about the sorts of
things that doctor who deals with it
people can latch on to fiction as a
point of reference for dealing with
these concepts cuz way too often not so
much the doctor who specifically but it
seems to whenever you get a lot of
really mind bendy time-travel II sort of
plot somebody who understands that I was
always going I can't possibly make you
comprehend but I love that in this they
just toss out a really easy to grasp on
pop culture arts oh so it's basically
that cool I like bad that's cool that's
fun
and it's an easy way to hook into the
thing now that said even though I really
like pretty much everything about this
show there's nothing I didn't like I'm
still going in with quite a bit of
caution because my feeling about art
drew spent up to this point is kind of
mixed when it comes to the Sarah Jane
Adventures I think they were very good
for what they were what they were wasn't
really for me them they were for younger
kids and again it did what it was trying
to do very well I just you know I
watched the episodes just so I couldn't
say that I watched them but I'll never
go back to ever see them again
Torchwood I towards what has about a
dozen really good episodes but I think
as a whole it just it didn't work it
didn't succeed at what it was trying to
do really it wasn't particularly
captivating and didn't know how to pace
itself properly so because of that
history I am cautious about this but
again if I take just the trailer by
itself this could be pretty good so
we'll see what we get is probably
unlikely that I will do any sort of
episode by episode things on this I may
not even get to it
for a little while
I will when I can find time be checking
this thing out when I can so have you
guys seen the trailer for class what do
you think about it I will say this the
name really generic doesn't really grab
you but aside from that what were your
thoughts on this trailer what are your
thoughts about the project or the idea
that are two spin-offs in general
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter a council of geeks check
out the Council of geeks podcasts on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned